[Music]
good morning
president Sall of a provost Pollock
Faculty of Arts and Sciences Dean
Gendler Graduate School Dean Cooley the
offices of the university the heads and
Dean's of the residential colleges and
the deans and members of the Yale
College Dean's office all join me in
welcoming you to you we have been
waiting a long time to meet you and we
are glad that you are finally here I
want to extend my welcome to the family
members and friends who are here today
it is thanks to your support and
guidance that Yale has the privilege of
hosting these impressive young adults
class of 2021 across the entire three
hundred and sixteen year history of Yale
College you are absolutely the greatest
in number you are arriving at Yale at
one of its most exciting moments two new
colleges are opening their gates for the
first time one is being rededicated and
magnificent new spaces to support
undergraduate life have recently opened
the campus is alive with activity and it
is waiting for you to explore it I've
been a teacher and researcher in
psychology and neuroscience at Yale for
17 years and a college head for nine of
those years but this is my first year as
dean of Yale College so like you I'm
gaining new opportunities and
responsibilities like you I'm eager to
build on what I know and enjoy while
exploring novel ideas and pursuits
president salivate has set Yale to be
the research university most committed
to teaching and learning this means that
my job is Dean is to ensure that you
have the best possible experiences both
inside and outside of the classroom at
Yale and to help you get you started I
would like to share with you some wisdom
that I have gained from your
predecessors in college you will
discover if you haven't already that
your biggest challenge is that there are
too many things to try and too little
time to do everything you'll soon be
getting a lot of advice about time
management and how to make choices to
start my first suggestion is to slow
down take things one at a time so let me
ask you a question when you study how
many of you can concentrate on your work
for hours without checking your phone or
your social media accounts or your email
don't be shy raise your hand if you fall
in that category I see thank you for
your honesty
if you're like most people you multitask
you might juggle lots of things at once
because you think you have to because
you're so busy or because you think it
makes you more efficient it's true that
multitasking is possible but research
shows that it comes at a severe cost let
me demonstrate
if you look inside your program you'll
find an insert and we'll be using this
insert during my address look in the
middle at demo number one the first line
of numbers half of these numbers are
black half are outlined white and your
task starting from the left is to look
at each number in the line check its
color if the number is black add 7 to
the number and whisper out the answer
and then move on to the next number
you're going to do this as quickly as
possible if the number is white you're
going to be subtracting 7 from that
number and moving on to the next number
so we want you to go as fast as you can
this is your QR test and when you're
done with a row with the eight numbers
you can snap your fingers like that so I
can hear when people are done and I
encourage the students to finish more
quickly than the people up in the
balcony all right so here we go we're
just doing demo number one starting with
that first number and here we go go
okay main floor is winning great
excellent
okay now go to net demo number two
you're doing the exact same thing if the
number is black at seven if the numbers
white subtract seven go as fast as you
can and snap at the end ready go
okay so thank you yeah we're done
people have another coffee uh-huh the
second demo the second point of course
is that the second demo I hope felt a
little bit harder despite having had a
little practice and this second line
that second demo is a simulation of
multitasking and task switching which is
required when you're trying to do more
than one thing at a time and compared to
doing the same problems and compared to
focusing on the same task at a time if
we measured your performance properly
using a timer we would have found that
people are about 30% slower and about
30% less accurate you make about 30%
more errors in the second version and
the verdant his first version if we had
you do this for a longer period of time
if I were to scan your brain while you
were multitasking while you were doing
the second demo compared to the first
one we I will find that your brain is
actually physically working harder to
switch back and forth to multitask
compared to when you were doing just one
task at a time it's almost like
switching back and forth between tasks
is like putting on a heavy backpack you
know while you're running you're
burdening yourself so my simple
practical first suggestion for
maximizing your study time is to turn
off your phones and social media alerts
while you study you know it's not like I
want you to turn those off all together
you know please do reward yourself by
promising to check maybe once an hour
once every 75 minutes but you know try
to drop the burdensome load of
multitasking and focus on the task in
front of you time management is a key to
success at a busy place like Yale I have
a second suggestion and let me
demonstrate again using the insert in
your program look at the image at the
top and name out loud what you see
okay so we're hearing different things
how many of you saw it duck okay okay
good you lower your hand how many saw
rabbit good okay look around everyone
has different answers here how many of
you can see it both ways now oh wow
excellent Wow
I can graduate this simple demonstration
shows a fundamental principle of
psychology we all experience the world
differently our perceptual
interpretations our memories and our
thoughts are all constructs of the mind
and they differ across people even when
we're considering the same object or
event most situations in life have
multiple valid interpretations and in
order to best confront such ambiguity we
must learn to see other perspectives and
for that we must have an open mind and
appreciate the different interpretations
around us Yale values these differences
because they are everywhere in the world
and in order to become good citizens and
leaders of this world we need to be
comfortable with difference not just to
accept it or tolerate it but to insist
on it whether it's political cultural
ethnic or skill based Yale needs to be a
place where you feel comfortable to
listen and to speak up both inside and
outside of the classroom a goal of this
fabulous liberal arts education that
awaits you is not just to give you
knowledge but the ability to analyze new
problems from multiple angles you need
to see both the duck and the rabbit and
I see that you already know how to
finally look at demo number three at the
bottom of the page and you see a bunch
of letters which form a code and my
question to you is what code this is
signify and if you think you've guessed
you can raise your hand although I won't
call on you okay here's the answer the
letters are my first year grades in
college
[Applause]
that was very affirmative thank you and
I can finally accept my grades now my
first year GPA was around two point now
and out of a 4.0 as a budding psychology
major I took two terms of introduction
to psychology which is what I teach here
at you
my first term grade in intro psych was a
B well my second term grade was a C one
of the C's you see there at Yale I'm
grateful to have an award for Teaching
Excellence in the social sciences a
course in which I earned the grade of D
by the way I showed president salivate
these grades after I was appointed Dean
and he warmly assured me that I can keep
my job but we both agreed that I should
clarify that I am not advocating that
you get such grades here at Yale so
parents who can be assured the immediate
question of course is how did I go from
grades like these to getting full
fellowship offers for PhD training at
MIT in Stanford I chose MIT postdoctoral
training at Harvard a professorship with
tenure at Yale where I was fortunate to
become an award-winning teacher and
researcher a college head and now Dean
one quick answer is that I am resilient
I did not give up and I worked hard I'm
not showing you my subsequent grades
because they're mostly just days that
said my overall GPA was still low and my
point is that you can't summarize your
college experience with a number I hope
that you will start to define your time
at Yale differently than you may have in
the past now in a richer more holistic
way will you find courses and activities
about which you feel passionate in which
you are creative and effective from
which you can contribute meaningfully to
others around you now here's the biggest
reason that I was able to recover from
these first year grades I was blessed
with outstanding Mentors
I found generous friends with whom I
exchanged notes and formed a study group
I looked up and looked up to an
impressive graduate student teaching
fellow who is now one of my closest
friends and most important and inspiring
faculty member took me under his wing
after seeing something in me that I
couldn't see in myself
professor Chung encouraged my studies
and gave me research opportunities and
he successfully supported me for
fellowships and for graduate school and
even beyond school I have had terrific
mentors throughout my career most
important is my wife of 21 years Yale
professor Liu Kang Han without whom I
would definitely not be standing here
today and even moving forward in my role
as Dean I will be relying on an
exceptional cohort of mentors many
sitting right behind me as you navigate
your way around Yale my final suggestion
to you is to find your mentors they are
everywhere Yale has already designated
several faculty members eager to help
you your college head your college dean
your college advisor when you start
taking classes your professors will want
to get to know you but you need to take
the first step of lingering after class
going to office hours or asking good
questions over email if you're active in
a cultural center the Dean and directors
could be your mentor if you're playing a
sport for Yale you have coaches whether
you're religious or not our chaplains
are eager to guide you if you're working
as we hope you do during your
extracurricular time and summers your
supervisor may teach you as much as you
would learn from any class in addition
you all have a first year counselor
eager to help your transition don't
underestimate the value of your proko
with Yale specific experience in
training helpful peer liaisons will also
be joining your Yale student mentorship
team an important benefit of having a
good mentor is that it makes you a good
teacher and example to others mentoring
others is a form of service that pays
for it sharing your experience and
talents is how you will make leading
contributions to society in every career
path not just friends around your age
but you can even teach those more
experienced than you some of my best
mentors have been my students so
remember this day as an opportunity to
appreciate all the mentoring you
Seve so far not just from your
instructors but from the parents and
family teachers coaches supervisors and
friends who have been part of your
journey some of them here with you today
as you take your first steps in this new
place I hope you will join me in
applauding them as they applaud you
congratulations again and welcome to
Yale
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning and welcome to my
colleagues here on the stage to the
family members or here with us today and
most of all to the class of 2021 I want
to give a special shout out to Marvin
Chun who is beginning his first year as
the new dean of Yale College and I know
you all enjoyed his remarks just as much
as I did to Marvin
a few years ago I helped a friend a
member of the Yale College class of 1982
in fact I helped him teach a Yale
College seminar called great big ideas
each week students in the seminar
considered a big idea from a different
field of study for homework they watched
video lectures delivered by various
experts and read primary sources then
they came to the class ready to debate
each week's big idea by the end of the
course they had become conversant in
major debates and questions in our
history political philosophy
evolutionary biology and other fields as
well my friend described the educational
impact of the course as a mile wide and
an inch deep I was thinking about great
big ideas over the summer reflecting on
the goal for the course reminded me of
the story of the Fox and the Hedgehog
now this is a distinction attributed to
our Kela kiss the seventh century BC
Greek poet and warrior who said a fox
knows many things but a hedgehog one
important thing
Fox knows many things but a hedgehog one
important thing when threatened the Fox
remains flexible coming up with a clever
way to deal with the particular matter
at hand the Hedgehog however responds
the same way to every threat it rolls up
into a ball the Fox is wily and
resilient the Hedgehog consistent but
inflexible the philosopher Isaiah Berlin
popularized this distinction in a 1953
essay Berlin described the Hedgehog as a
thinker who sees the world through a
single grand idea a focused lens someone
like Karl Marx or Ayn Rand might be
considered a hedgehog the Fox on the
other hand becomes knowledgeable
knowledgeable about many different
things
it draws on a multitude of ideas and
experiences depending on the situation
at hand
perhaps Confucius and Aristotle are best
described as foxes as Berlin says there
exists a great chasm between those on
one side who relate everything to a
single vision a single Universal
organizing principle the hedgehogs and
those who pursue many ends often
unrelated and even contradictory
connected if at all in some defect away
these are the foxes this dichotomy is
obviously an oversimplification as
Berlin himself recognized I'm actually
reminded of an old joke about there
being two kinds of psychologists those
who believe that humanity can be divided
into two types of people and those who
do not in any case the story of the Fox
and the Hedgehog may help you today
right now as you consider how to
approach your time at Yale your
education in your college will expose
you to some grand ideas that may seem
compelling as unifying life philosophies
we will learn about and from some
brilliant hedgehogs and brilliant foxes
but at this stage of your education I
want to urge you to emulate the Fox as
inspired as you might be by a single
idea or way of looking at the world I
suggest that you entertain many
different ways of thinking and consider
various points of view try them all on
see what fits you best the beauty of a
liberal education the education that
Yale College offers is that it liberates
you from having to pursue a narrow
vocationally oriented program of study I
hope you will take advantage of and
enjoy this intellectual freedom you will
be able to choose from a wide variety of
courses learning about how people in
many different fields think and
understand the world your professors
will introduce you to a panoply of ideas
and ask you to think critically about
all of them you will be expected to come
to question conventional orthodoxies
rather than subscribe to a single view
of the world this work will be
challenging have no doubt but it will
also be exhilarating and yes liberating
there'll be plenty of time later to hone
your focus to specialize and develop
your expertise perhaps you'll decide to
pursue a doctorate or attend
professional school and there may even
be times here at Yale College when you
will delve deeply into a certain topic
for a paper or a project when I received
my graduate education here at Yale for
example there were times when I had to
be a hedgehog
hedgehogs to have many fine qualities
but over the years I have loved seeing
generations of Yale college students
embrace the opportunity to think broadly
and study widely you will also develop
as flexible thinkers and clear
communicators these fox-like attributes
will serve you well no matter what you
do after graduation in fact there are
good reasons to believe that learning to
think like a fox may play important
dividends as many of you know I'm a
psychologist and my research and
teaching have focused in the field of
social psychology and there's a social
psychology
just named Philip tetlock at the
University of Pennsylvania who has
studied the ability of foxes versus
hedgehogs the humankind to predict and
prepare for the future tetlock completed
his doctoral work here at Yale in our
Department of Psychology by the way tat
Locke's research is focused on political
judgment the accuracy with which
politicians experts pundits and others
predict outcomes in the world and how
various actions might affect these
outcomes so for example what a hardline
foreign policy by the United States with
respect to North Korea weakened chairman
Kim's ironclad grip on that country yes
or no how likely well President Assad's
regime in Syria fall in the next year
yes or no how likely Ted Locke studied
284 prognosticators experts who are paid
to offer answers to questions in which
they must predict the future about
various world events he analyzed eighty
two thousand three hundred and sixty one
probability estimates made by these
individuals in response to twenty-seven
thousand four hundred and fifty
forecasting questions studying as well
how they came to these judgments and how
they reacted when they were wrong
whether they revised their forecasts in
response to new evidence he found that
specialists and making predictions about
such situations are about as accurate as
you or I would be consider that highly
trained well-paid experts are no more
likely to be correct when predicting
future events than ordinary people
well-established Talking Heads are worst
of all they often stubbornly and over
confidently adhere to their original
theories the ideas most associated with
them
even in the face of overwhelming
evidence that they are wrong like
hedgehogs they stick with the point of
view that made them famous and are
dismissive of new information that
contradicts their beliefs they roll up
into a ball
however Ted tetlock did find some
individuals who were better at
predicting the future as he describes
them these are thicker z' who know many
small things tricks of the trade they
are skeptical of grand schemes and they
are willing to stitch together diverse
sources of information perhaps most
important they are not overly confident
in their own forecasting prowess in
other words they are humble critical
well-informed and flexible think
thinkers in short they are foxes foxes
are the best prognosticators so what
does the Fox say
so you're gonna explain to your parents
what that was all about right that was
between us and six hundred and six
hundred and eighty million people who
have viewed that YouTube video the Fox
says Fox doesn't say hidey-ho and he
says on the video what the [ __ ] says is
I want to listen carefully engage
explore use my natural curiosity and
perhaps in the end outwit the others
foxes don't get information only from
sources with which they agree when
confronted by contrary ideas the Fox
says bring it on foxes are resilient and
they not only respond better to
challenges they may even be able to
predict what challenges they will face
down the road better than their Hedgehog
friends all around us we are surrounded
by foxes who have shaped our lives and
our world in the last few days some of
you moved into one of Yale's two new
residential colleges Pauli Murray or
Benjamin Franklin I'm thrilled that we
can offer a young college education to
15% more students in each cohort
starting with you the class of 2021 and
it's amazing how lovely and yell like
the new colleges are and yes you can
still create gothic architecture in 2017
others of you are the first to live as
freshmen in Grace Hopper College you are
also you are also part of something new
and exciting Benjamin Franklin Pauli
Murray grace hopper are three new
college namesakes they share some common
attributes all three were curious
individuals who never stopped learning
new things and all of them were
exemplary foxes it's probably obvious to
you that Ben Franklin had a fox-like
intellect
drew upon it as an inventor a statesman
a writer his response to seemingly
insurmountable challenges invent
something and so Franklin witnessing the
destructive power of electricity
develops the lightning rod has
difficulty seeing both near and far in
middle age and so invents bifocals needs
a source of indoor heating less smokey
than a fireplace and therefore builds
what we now call the Franklin stove and
I don't even want to know what problem
he was trying to solve when he invented
the flexible catheter as a diplomat
Franklin's contributions to
international relations were
characterized less by ideology the
Hedgehog's approach and more by flexible
statesmanship a fox-like strategy he
gained the support of France for the
cause of American independence by
articulating Enlightenment ideas to an
appreciative audience endearing himself
and his insights to his French
counterparts moreover Franklin was
perfectly willing to change his mind as
evidenced by his embrace of the
abolitionist cause later in his life two
centuries hence Pauli Murray arrived at
Yale to complete a doctorate in law by
this point she was already an
accomplished attorney and civil rights
pioneer when Murray was at Yale her
first her friend Eleanor Roosevelt
tapped her to serve on the President's
Commission on the status of women it was
during this time that Murray developed
the novel approach of using the 14th
amendment to combat sex discrimination
doing the research to support her ideas
right here in Sterling Library legal
scholars up until that time had viewed
this amendment as providing due process
and equal protection under the law
regardless of race religion or heritage
but Murray saw it as another path she
saw in it another path for the
advancement of civil rights short time
later while working on her thesis in New
Haven Murray wrote a memorandum that
helped ensure the inclusion of
protections on the basis of sex in the
Civil Rights Act of 1964 Pauli Murray
was many things a poet writer an
attorney a legal scholar an advocate for
racial justice and one of the founders
of the National Organization for Women
she never stopped learning or trying new
things at age 62 she entered the general
Theological Seminary in New York and
three years later became the first
African American woman to be ordained as
an Episcopal priest throughout her life
she listened learned and adapted to new
challenges with astonishing success
finally Admiral Grace Hopper she
epitomizes the Fox the Fox is flexible
intellect she received her PhD in
mathematics from Yale and after Pearl
Harbor she enlisted in the Navy where
she was assigned to work on one of the
world's first computers although her
preparation in mathematics was important
Hopper had to think beyond what she had
learned in school Yale had not taught
her to be a computer scientist in fact
the profession didn't really even exist
yet but she had learned to think and
solve problems Hopper loved to say the
most damaging words in the English
language are it's always been done that
way so a lifelong maverick Grace Hopper
relied on her curiosity and her
willingness to take risks and in the
process she transformed the way we use
computers influencing all our lives
members of the class of 2021 I'm proud
and delighted that you will be able to
pursue an education here at Yale like
Franklin Murray
hopper and a host of other foxes you
will develop your intellect in broad and
flexible ways you will learn to be
careful thinkers suspicious of easy
answers and received wisdom you will
hone these skills so that you may work
effectively with others in the words of
Yale's mission statement you will work
with others to improve the world today
and for future generations I know that
you will experience great pleasure in
becoming foxes yourselves and so I
congratulate you
class of 2021 and welcome you to Yale
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
my beloved Yale family as we ready
ourselves to step out onto new ground in
this daunting yet inspiring liminal
space of the unknown next we begin a
poignant turn of goodbyes and hellos
that invite laughter tears challenge
choice discovery and pride let us go
forth with deep trust in certain
knowledge that this splendid place
welcomes each one of us that love
surrounds us that beauty can surprise us
that truth and light awaits us on this
day and every day forward may all that
is holy shine upon us and tenderly bless
our every breath may we go in Shalom in
Salaam in Shanti may we go in peace let
us begin
[Music]